it's on councillor
thank you very much indeed
right good afternoon
members uh and good afternoon to uh
members of the public that may have
tuned into the rockford district council
youtube channel
this is a meeting of the
flood forum
for today first of november
and uh i would certainly like to welcome
everyone uh i've heard that uh
councillor mrs cheryl rowe may be
running a little bit late or may not get
here at all depending on her work
commitments
um and
i think
i can't see
counselor
carol weston um can i no i can't see
carol weston
has anyone received apologies from carol
no okay
um but um
i would like to
give a brief warm welcome to council mrs
christine mason and councillor chris
stanley um
certainly
when i was talking with the portfolio
holder
last week he certainly agreed that this
forum should be an inclusive forum
for uh all members across party uh and
um more importantly across the uh
geographical district of rochford um so
that seems to be a sensible way to uh
move forward so
hopefully all members agree with me on
that
um
by way of
some background
you need to go back to
2014 uh 25th of february 2014 to be
precise when uh this flood forum was
formed and i would like to say that it
is not just a um
as
from an rdc point of view this is not a
statutory function
but it is right and proper that we
coordinate the agencies we do have
responsibility and work with them
to deal with specific flooding issues
across the
geography of our district
uh thanks to
jeff stacy who will be leading us
through the meeting this afternoon with
various items
and at the end
i want to take views from members please
as to whether or not not withstanding my
comments back in uh
march i think when we had our last
forum
that hopefully this meeting would be
in person uh actually reflecting with
the portfolio holder last week we
actually feel this is one of those
meetings that moving forward uh is
probably quite effective through a
virtual platform so i will be taking
members views at the end of this meeting
so without further ado um can we agree
item two
the
minutes of the meeting held on the 9th
of march earlier this year
on points of accuracy please
and can i um
have any comments councillor laureen
shaw
sorry i was just to put my hand up to
agree simon sorry all right okay um well
if you can either signify by your actual
hand um or um
virtually if you can signify your
agreement that would be uh be helpful
please
you can raise your hands
with agreements
yup i think that's got everyone's
agreement as far as i can
as far as i can see
thank you um
right moving on to matters arising and
what i would appreciate is if it's
possible please to take matters arising
which do not
feature anywhere else on the um
list that
jeff stacy had prepared for us because
it would be helpful if we keep some
structure in order to uh for the meeting
to
overlap but are there any matters
arising from the minutes please
no okay
ah kelsey stepped out
rising but i don't see on the um agenda
declarations of interest and i do need
to declare something oh that's a really
good point thank you councillor scepto
i think that is omitted and you're right
absolutely right to point that out so uh
under um
uh
well can we take any declarations please
i assume uh councillor stefano you might
have have one to make
yeah i've got two or three to be honest
with you i
met member of barney parish council and
because a couple of matters that may
come up for that i'm also a member of
the essex flood vice chairman of the
essex flag forum and i'm also a member
of the environmental agency rf
rfc fc group as well
thank you have you got that
veronica
lovely thank you very much
uh council christine mason
uh thank you simon um
i've just noticed that my road is down
there so i should declare an interest
as as it's been reported okay thank you
single feel close okay that's kind of
you thank you very much indeed and
councillor chris stanley
uh thank you chairman uh just to inform
the committee that i'm working with the
roy flood action group
uh from my particular area thank you and
you're declaring that there's an
interest in this meeting yes i am yes
thank you
councillor dave spirit
thank you chairman member of brady town
council just in case any of these areas
uh impinge on that situation just to
cover the options thank you
thank you very much councilman sperring
councillor judy gooding
yeah i'd just like to declare i did
mention the rectory road and i lived
there so just declaring interest thank
you
thank you very much indeed i think
that's covered everyone with their hands
up oh counselor in ward
yeah i put my hand up first and you kind
of omitted me completely
it's not a nice bright yellow one
all right i don't know why
i have no idea
anyway uh raineytown council and also a
member and uh
of
rochford the
golf club roger 100 which does appear on
there because of flooding
right
thank you council award nothing personal
um
veronica have you got all of those
right as we go through um if anyone
becomes aware of an area they need to
record the declaration of interest
please um make them aware and i will add
mine as a member of rochefort hundred
golf club please you can add that please
veronica um so really good point thank
you councillor septo for raising that
that's a very important point thank you
um
council stanley you have your hand up
uh no i'm trying to uh take it down
thank you
okay all right good luck on that one
right okay
right that
moves us on to
uh verbal updates from partners and uh
i'm very pleased to welcome mr david
chapman
as its county council good to see you uh
mr chapman um
really pleased that this time um essex
county council have supported us
by attending the meeting and i think we
were expecting mr roger webster from the
environment agency and he's here
he's on there yes so uh welcome to you
mr webster good afternoon everybody here
and um mark lloyd from angry and water
um and
he's here
just from his work thank you councilor
um and the system seems to be working
quite well so
welcome gentlemen um
and
i think that completes all the partner
agencies with us so that's really good
thank you very much indeed your time
this afternoon
so um the next
item as i say is item for verbal updates
from partners so environment agency we
um
we
revert to mr webster if you want to
cover any general items before we get
into the um
specifics
on the agenda today
uh i just wanted to um make you aware
that i've been working with dave chapman
and
councillor stanley i'm looking at the
issues
at roarworth and rorth the shot uh we're
currently working or looking at options
for a scheme upstream
on the three main rivers that uh drain
into aurora so
north bentley brought chichester hall
brook and roloff brook
we're looking to work with um the
friends of wic country park which i know
is in basildon area but we're trying to
look at ways of slowing the flows and
storing flows upstream
of
aurora to manage the flows
so i've been working in partnership with
those partners
um
i've been on a couple of well one site
meeting with
jeff
down at which i think is on there
kimberly road
so we've there's other visits that we're
going to be looking at as well in the
future
down near the fire station
in um
rayleigh as well where there's a
flooding issue
so yeah that's that's basically the
moment thank you very much indeed and if
we can go to
um anglia water
mark lloyd
right it doesn't look as if
mark lloyd is receiving us we're
certainly not receiving him
so while hopefully mark lloyd can sort
out his um
sound issues uh can we move to um
the um
baby chapman basics county council
afternoon everyone um just to follow on
from what roger said at rorith we are
also looking at um
delivering some highway upgrades as part
of that so there's a two-phased approach
so the the work that roger is looking at
and we're working with him on uh on whit
country park and more of shop but also i
have got a contractor uh looking at some
of the small small interventions that
was uh part of our discussion with
councillor stanley
uh marcus hotten when we went out to
church road roar as well
i'm still waiting for the contract to
get back to me on that one but we are
looking to hopefully progress those uh
in the not too distant future so i'll
keep everybody in the loop and when more
information becomes available
that's good thank you very much indeed
for that overview and update and
we go back to mark lloyd to see whether
mark has been able to connect
uh sadly it appears not um it would be
quite nice if um
jeff veronica sonia whoever's on the
line are able to try and make contact
and
see see why
not coming through
thank you very much indeed um
right okay uh i think we move now to
jeff stacey to take us through the main
meet of the um
uh of the
agenda uh which he's going through in
order and i before
i hand over to jeff i do want to
thank you very much indeed jeff for
doing what um we asked in the last one
forum is putting a much better structure
and order into these issues so that we
can go through area by area uh
understand
um
what the issue is
and
the action
needed and who is going to take
ownership of that action i think you've
made a significantly good start on um
on moving forward with that i know since
the agenda was issued you've further
updated that report but i think we'll
pass over to you to guide us through uh
item five on rdc update reports of
flooding issues uh along with our
partners can i head over to you jeff
please
thank you very much mr chairman um
it's just sort of really going through
um
all the the issues that have either been
notified to to us
both through the forum and at any time
sort of during the year
and this is an opportunity
just to just look at progress and and
sort of see where we are um and get some
up-to-date comments from from partners
um i'll incorporate those into an update
of the uh the sort of list of issues
that we've got
and then that can go out with the
minutes to
to give us a summary of where we are
with all these different issues
um so going through them in in in order
um
the first one is ashington
i've even put them in alcohol order
um
first one is ashington lower road uh and
ashington road
um which was some work to uh was
proposed by isis county council highways
um
i've got some comments here from uh
directly from highways from richard
i don't know
uh dave chapman if if you want to cover
those or whether you just want me to to
run through comments
unfortunately
i don't have any information from essex
county highways i'm not here to sort of
represent them hopefully
i was thinking that maybe richard
baronovsky or somebody from highways
would be here but it doesn't look what
they are so
um jeff i don't have any ad other than
what you've already got from my
colleagues in highways okay
no that's fine i'll i'll cover the uh
the comments that uh roger sent me just
before the meeting so uh richard sent me
just before the meeting so that's fine
thank you
um yes the the issue there was uh six
highways comment
um
they haven't attended uh due to traffic
management and permit difficulties
at this time not aware of any serious
flooding here although i will be
attending when an opportunity arises
um i think they they did actually make a
an attempt to do some work there but
found that they needed to
have a proper
traffic management system before they
could do that effectively
um
[Music]
the the next one is 29 brazed lane
thank you simon um jeff i've been
speaking with lee scott on this for
highways down ashland road they've got a
problem
they've told max some of the drains down
there because they haven't got um the
drain covers to
complete the jobs and they don't know
when they're getting them so that is
going to not help the
flooding issue at all there i've chased
early again today before we come into
this meeting so that's just an update
that they're around the region they're
actually putting
temporary
solutions which isn't they're tarmacking
over the drains
okay so it isn't helping
yeah i just thought i'd let give you an
update
okay
thank you thank you for that and uh just
uh i would certainly like to make a
point there thank you um
counselor lauren shaw um i think this is
going to be rather repetitive when we're
talking about pavement
and street flooding i get extremely
frustrated at the general lack of
maintenance by
the county council and highways on
clearing out drains i don't think we can
be surprised
that
we receive flooding when
our
infrastructure that is supposed to
remove water
is blocked or not regularly maintained
so
i think that's going to be a bit of a
repetitive issue because it is quite
clear to me as i ride around the
district that there are many drains in
this area that are blocked through
natural causes or um now i say people
that have building work done uh it seems
to be
a way that builders sweep
their
bits of mess sand and rubbish down
drains but uh
it does does cause me quite a bit of
frustration and counsellor mike stepler
he's picking up on what you're saying
there and simon it's uh i think i'm
going to
to partly involve rochford with this
uh i've got a particular issue around
walnuts bridge
where
uh drains are getting blocked up with
the detroiters that he's left on the
side of the road
uh i don't believe what the council is
clearing the side of the roads regularly
enough
um and if you look at you go up walnut
bridge from watchful led you can see a
massive buildup of mud that is on the
side of the road it is simply not being
cleared so i think there is some
liability in the road sweeping aspect of
rockford district council itself
yep now a really good point and thank
you for that and somewhere veronica
you'll pick that up in a minute so that
we can put all of this together um but
that's more of a general point sorry to
depart from the specifics um
but jeff back to you on
running through your list
unfortunately you're on mute jeff
yes i'm just saying a lot of some
technical issues here unfortunately my
screen's gone blank so i can't see what
the next one there
was i believe that was uh braised lane
29th break right now
yeah just trying to get my screen back
um yes there was there was a an issue
there which um
was investigated and i believe they
found
uh no no specific problems there so uh
no further action on
that one
um
just jump in there
yeah sure
um
basically uh the the site was
investigated by as it says on the on the
minute our uh watercourse regulation
engineer he's actually carried out what
we call a section 23 which is a
consenting process
so all of the actions down there have
now been covered
by an official consent
lovely thank you very much indeed and um
so if everyone agrees that will be
closed on this listing but it will still
be visual for us
to see um so that would build up a uh a
log of
actions taken and actions close
thank you for that moving on to moons
close to uh high cliff present
uh
jeff stacy you're a mute
chairman
yes
uh do we have anybody else to take over
while jeffy's trying to sort himself out
because we could be here for
quite considerable time if we carry on
like this well i agree um but the answer
short answer to your question is no
okay
um because jeff is our responsible
officer within rdc that pulls all this
together so um i'm afraid i'm a little
bit in jeff's hands but i do agree with
you um it could be a little laborious so
we're trying to speed it up once we get
links back to him
jeff you're mute
are you able to get the mute off for
i think the answer to that is no
maybe he should go out and come back in
again
a few chairman mark lloyd has sent an
apologies for technical issues
he can hear you but can't hear for some
reason but you can't hear him
all right i think we had this problem
last time with anglia walter
maybe again mark may wish to get out and
then come back in again try again
this is all now starting to be a good
reason why we don't have this virtually
but i would have thought this was an
ideal meeting if people's assistant
don't have virtually but which is a
little frustrating
well mark has taken that advice and has
gone out and tried to reconnect again
and what i am going to ask um
is that officers generally if they have
unreliable
internet collections at home
um they should be using their office
systems to actually conduct these
meetings this is an official meeting and
if their own
internet is unstable from home
i'm afraid they need to be in their
office where hopefully it can be more
stable
um sorry i'm ignoring the hands up
counselor uh joe mcpherson
uh thank you chairman it's some only an
idea if one of our other officers could
share the agenda
if mr stacy can see that then at least
he can read from the screen and we can
go through it as a team
and our uh guests can contribute through
it
i know
i agree i mean we'll have to review
things if uh in the light of experience
from this meeting um but uh counselor
mrs christine mason
thank you mr chairman i think one of the
problems is you've quite
um identified is if someone's working
from home with an unstable internet
connection
but obviously if they're in the office
they would have the opportunity to go to
another
office and use another screen so
it's certainly something that needs to
be looked into for the future absolutely
couldn't agree more
and it looks as if mark lloyd might have
joined us
yeah apologies um i [ __ ] hear you all
when you can hear me now
and see you
oh nice we're getting there we're
getting yep
that's
that's moving forward
uh there's no real update from us at the
moment but obviously we'll comment or
anything we need to assist with
when we go through the list
yeah i can communicate with you now
which is
it's a good start now we're moving
moving forward thank you very much
indeed mark
jeff
stacy are you back with us
right and
in the absence of jeff
i'm just going to go through the list
and see whether or not we can um we can
get any comments please um from the lead
agency uh moons close to high cliff
present is where i believe we are um and
um
the lead agency there is essex county
highway so we look to you david have you
got anything you can help us with
no unfortunately council would not have
said is that the updates uh from richard
which i'm assuming he sent over to to
jeff
um so jeff can then update i don't have
any contact with richard i don't have
any update on
essex highways matters i'm afraid
okay um
thank you
um councillor laurene
shaw thank you simon sorry i had to turn
my screen off but it was actually lee
scott that was bringing me on another
matter
and i did make sure we were having this
highways and davey couldn't answer the
questions for highways he said if we
need to reschedule another meeting on
this he will do thank you
thank you very much indeed um
we can't continue like this this is
hopeless um councillor chris stanley
you chairman um
the moon's close says that um the essex
uh highways will be
we'll send a jetting crew and check with
anglian walter can anglia walter uh give
us an update have they have they've been
in contact with the highways and got it
jetted
right well what i'm concerned about is
it's all going to get a little
unstructured because um um
you're right to sort of be asking the
question but
jeff stacy is our cold inaudible
might be
jeff might be back um
so uh jeff are you
there's something coming back if you can
hear me yes
good
right okay could we just have one voice
at the time please
we just sort of keep it fairly formal in
terms of structure otherwise uh
we get cross cross voices um right um
jeff uh we were on moons close but we're
hoping to speed up the agenda a bit can
you just talk me through that one yeah
okay um essex highways comment uh
this was last attended in december 2020
by our jetting crew
at that time no issues were found with
our drainage system
the jetting report again suggests
downstream capacity issues under heavy
rainfall
and then in brackets that's an anglian
water responsibility
the cyclical gully cleanse is due in
rochford on the main road network in the
latter part of 2021 and we'll be
starting shortly
thank you very much uh no further
comments i see on that one when we move
on to 621 ashing the road
yeah again an essex highways comment
block ditches were attended in this
vicinity a number of years ago
a gully defect was raised by a highways
inspector earlier this year
this defect was attended on the 28th of
october
and was cleared
so that's obviously fairly recent so
we wait to see how effective that
is lovely thank you very much indeed
again no
hands there we move on i think to
battles bridge battles
uh
yes yeah i did a visit there um
and uh produced a report specifically on
that area because there were a number of
issues
and the essex highways comment is um
around the timberwolf cottages uh that's
obviously a private road it's not
maintainable public highway
um
and apart from that they say we are not
aware of any drainage issues at the
chelmsford road
beaches road junction
um which was was not the information
that uh that i was given so we'll have
to follow that one up again
okay councilman chris stanley you put up
your hand
yes thank you chairman um could i ask
the question uh for the battles bridge
area was the
was the gates or the
i don't know whether you call it the
gates or whatever you call it
once they um are they uh maintained as
open
and not closed at any particular time
and
sorry not something i have any knowledge
of
do we have any knowledge from the uh
environment agency or the flood
uh dave chapman
uh nothing from me council stanley
oh sorry i don't know anything about
those either
i'm afraid
could i just say that it seems strange
that we don't know anything about them
and yet um that's where all the water's
going
to
uh from all areas so
somebody's got to have control of them
perhaps that could be put on the agenda
for next time please yeah i agree and
that your comments have been noted and
certainly that's the reason we're going
through this stuff so that we get
someone who coordinates and takes
ownership of a particular issue that is
is raised so thank you council standing
um
great i think we're on to canute now
yeah um
yes a comment from essex highways on
this one was
uh no location details if we can provide
some further details they'll investigate
um
i don't know if anybody has got any
further information on that one if not
i'll refer back to my original notes and
get back in touch with whoever
raised that in the first place i think
councillor laurene shaw may be offering
to help there
yeah if this was not been going on for a
couple of years now it's off scott's
hall road
you get to the junction there
you're going to anchor lane
if you turn left
to lance hill it's a drain there
literally on the corner of anchor lane
scots hall
they came highways came and did tarmac
the road
and put all their rubbish down the drain
and that's where it's blocked
thank you and i pointed this out when we
were
at
raley chamber
thank you very much indeed um
disappointing to see that it's still on
the list in that case if we've already
identified location and um
uh not been resolved
um
haggleshawn
yes uh again a fairly um
detailed comment from essex highways on
this one
the their comment is
this was passed across for further
investigations to be carried out as part
of a surface water alleviation scheme
the site has been visited and a
preliminary design has been explored
which would require extensive works
thus further avenues are currently being
explored and continued
with including a recent discussion with
anglin water
in the interim we will continue to
undertake preventative cleanses of the
existing soak away
three or four times a year
and undertake reactive maintenance
accordingly
the soak away was attended and cleaned
on the 28th of october
2021.
okay
before i bring councillor lauren shawin
um this is in my own ward area um the
word reactively is not acceptable to me
when the pub becomes regularly flooded
due to the inadequacy of the drainage
infrastructure they've been talking
about this for three years now and it
really is time that this one was sorted
out it's more than just cleaning out the
soak away then we keep talking about it
i've been involved in meetings and it's
not acceptable that places are regularly
flooded and yet the time just rolls
along without actually finding a
solution and that's all i wish to say
councillor lauren shaw
thank you as simon this is also in my
world um the late terry cutmore brought
this to
the attention in 2008 uh and we're still
arguing who is going to do this the guy
is having real problems at the pub and
last week i've got photographs this week
we've got photographs it is still being
flooded so they may have done a little
bit of work out there
but it certainly hasn't helped and we
really need to get this sorted as
as per our chairman has said thank you
okay thank you very much indeed um
right so absent hall road
uh yes an essex highways comment um
yes the system out falls to uh an open
ditch
uh this is this is a private drainage
system there
um
so the system out falls to an open ditch
so they're not seeing that as a highways
matter
they're saying that the ditch is
overwhelmed
so um
who is the owner of it then i suppose
that's my next question
uh yes i i would agree it's a
question of trying to establish who
who has responsibility for
maintenance of that ditch
right so that's an outstanding action um
have we got any further comments on that
one
that's an outstanding action that needs
to be councilman uh chris stanley
thank you chairman um
although it it is the the
right parent ownership of the ditch it's
where the water goes from that ditch
uh along to wherever it goes to as he's
got to drain away and if that is uh
blocked in any in any
shape or form the water is is obviously
going to overflow
so i would suggest if i may that uh
someone needs to check to where the
ditch actually runs to or where the
water would run to if it just overflows
thank you well i agree with you
councillor stanley our difficulty at the
moment is finding the someone
i agree with you but someone needs to
take ownership of it and uh can we leave
it to you jeff please to try and find
out who's going to take ownership
someone must be able to help on this
councillor
yeah thank you uh surely the arts is
simple it's the right parent landowner
they will be
okay
if i just stand in as well um
if the the details of the approximate
location are sent over to us at the
flood team and i can provide the generic
email if we don't have it already then
we can go out and have a look at the
riparian ownership responsibilities and
landowners from there and report back
uh that's really helpful thanks very
much indeed i mean what i'm keen to do
in the first incident you get who is the
uh responsible body um i'm quite relaxed
who they are but uh
agreeing if it's a riparian owner issue
or whether or not it's a statutory
authority
yes if you send the deeds and somebody
sends the details over if it's jeff then
then we can send that over to the inbox
and we'll we'll investigate from there
lovely okay moving on
clements hallway
yes if if uh if i may the the um
there were a number of of sort of issues
that were raised around
uh hawkwell
um
which i went in and investigated and
sort of traced it all through
they were all linked together to the the
hawkwell brook
um in clements hallway woodside chase
um and bellshamps
um
and
i've done a report that sort of links
all into to sort of all of those
um and i think it's really discussing in
the future with
with partners a a wider solution to the
the whole of the uh sort of hawkwell
brook
and what we might do there to uh
to sort of see what's happening
um certainly on the time i investigated
it was uh it was all sort of fairly
clear i mean you'll see a couple of
those reports relate to blockages due to
fly tipping and everything
um the only thing i found in the
uh the whole of the area i checked was
was one bike
um so that that seems to be sort of
fairly clear at the moment
but i want to look at a sort of wider
piece of work around the uh the hawk
well brook in in general
um and then just one final comment on
the
railway bridge at rectory road
um the essex highways comment
is that this was last cleared in march
they recognize it's a known low spot
and it is difficult for them to attend
to
due to difficulty with traffic
management
thanks um as i said earlier we can
record our decorations of interest if i
please veronica can i have my
declaration of interest uh recorded for
clement's hallway as i actually um live
on the christmas tree estate and
yeah so uh if that can be recorded and
you've
moved on to
the railway bridges that that's a linked
decent work you lit
and
not as much that's uh that's not
directly relating to the hawkwell brook
that's uh
i think that's more just sort of general
runoff and water in the road with it
with it being such a low spot where the
the road dips underneath the railway
bridge okay did i miss it but did you
talk about woodside chase
um
yeah woodside chase the the report there
was uh maintenance relating to the
removal of fly tipping
certainly at the time i
i attended there was there was nothing
there
okay anything that is linked to rdc to
investigate or look at
perhaps you would be kind enough to work
with other officers and the portfolio
holder to um get a structured approach
to how we move these things forward if
that's all right please jeff
yes i mean that one as i say it sort of
relates to the the halt will brook and
um
uh
when roger from the environment agency
spoke earlier he was talking about a
visit that we proposed
um unfortunately it had to be cancelled
last time
because of uh
well a number of problems including
flooding we we picked a bad day
um but we're rescheduling that and
there's a number of areas that we that
we want to look at that relate to this
okay thank you for that um you talk
about the railway bridge of retro road
and um
it just seems amazing to me that every
time we get something a little bit
excessive in rainfall we talk about
several bridges in the district um and i
just don't know why we can't get some
sort of permanent solution in place
because it causes absolute mayhem to
traffic uh when these areas are blocked
up and we just know they're going to be
blocked up because the infrastructure
there is inadequate and i think um there
should be a more determined effort to
find a solution in 2021
councillor judy gooding
yeah picking up on the the railway
bridge which obviously i've reported uh
many times uh to say that it's traffic
management which is the problem what is
the solution and what is jeff or the
authorities planning to to do to manage
the traffic management because we can't
just say it's a problem because we can't
manage the traffic it's got to be
cleaned out that's what was agreed in
our previous minutes
yes i can pass that comment on obviously
it's not
for me to comment on the um
sort of highways
operations um
as you say certainly we there is an
increased uh frequency of of of cleaning
but
that causes its own own disruption with
the with the traffic management whilst
they're doing it
um
but yes i'll certainly pass those
comments onto the uh essex highways
okay and presumably dave chapman you're
you're making a little note from an
essex point of view as well
yes yeah noted good um because you know
it seems to be a surprise to various
people that um under the number of
bridges that we have in this district
that we get a little bit more than
normal rainfall and i'm not talking
about extreme by any means that these
places flood and we really shouldn't be
experiencing this time and time again
um
and
if the cleaning regime or if the pumping
raging needs to be stepped up um so be
it it needs to be um be done um bell
shouts is next on my list
uh yes i mean that's that's part of the
the site visit i did which uh links into
the whole well brook report
uh which i say we're looking to
look at as a whole because they're all
sort of linked areas
um and there's there's possible
solutions uh that that may be able to
assist
really from sort of hotly woods right
through down to the uh the fire station
at uh at rockford
good okay moving on to hotly plumberrow
avenue
uh yes i have no update
on that
um
yeah i've got one from jeff if you like
um
so basically you might say that thank
you
the uh the planning commission 426 went
through our substitute for consultation
um back in 2019
and there was a number of conditions
placed on that site
that needed to be adhered to
now where that's gone through after that
process
i'd refer back to rockford district
council's uh planning department to see
whether or not those those uh conditions
have been adhered to but there were a
number attached to the consent that were
awarded for that situation
no no just acknowledging that uh that
one carry on please that's that's
helpful thank you very much
as far as i know uh from uh one of the
or quite a few of the residents uh very
little has been done and the problem is
still there
um yeah there is a an issue with
planning and enforcement i believe but
as yet
um a meeting was due to be
taken
with marcus hoffman and the residents in
that area
but that has not happened there are lots
of issues around there that need to be
you know clarified it's still ongoing
and a problem
okay yeah and certainly i'm aware of
that one and really we ought to be that
ought to be being resolved because if
there is a planning issue or for
whatever reason it is enforcement issues
we'll be dealing with that i'm sure that
the um the conditions have been passed
over as part of the consultation process
but if you need those to be recently i
can get somebody to send those over
there were three conditions that were
placed on that application as well so
if you need the more information is
needed then please let me know
thanks a lot westminster drive
uh yes that's that's a fairly recent one
on to the um
uh on onto the list of issues that i've
got
um i have visited there to sort of have
a look and see what the uh what the
concern is
and that's something i need to make some
further initial
inquiries about and
see where we can take that
thank you uh moving on to hull bridge
watery lane
uh yes an update from essex highways
here
um they're saying
a preventative cleanse was undertaken on
the 20th of the 9th 21.
we also cut back vegetation
we are aware the road flooded recently
however however we understand that the
flood water abated once the outflows had
cleared
i understand a request was made to rocha
district council to sweep the road
as there was substantial silt and debris
on the road
we will again undertake an inspection
with a view to a preventative cleanse in
the spring
although this may be brought forward
dependent on weather conditions later
this year
thank you
thank you
um
william all right
standing your hand is up
thank you chairman um i understand that
walter elaine is um
if you like closed off uh on the
wednesdays
for
um litter picking and and uh cleaning of
the the ditch of the drones
um is this still the
the is it is this still an ongoing uh
situation um and
are the are those drains cleared as they
should be thank you
anyone got an answer to councillor
stanley
no he would appear not but perhaps
councillor stanley's comments could be
noted and someone could get back to him
with a uh a response please
thank you chairman
moving on to malians
um
yeah so with concerns uh sent through to
me
over the um
flooding link to the um david wilson
development
um so i did go on site met with
representatives of the
developers
um looked at the arrangements they that
they had for
uh sort of controlling flood and
everything
and
[Music]
i i couldn't see that there was anything
that sort of related to the
to the site that was affecting nearby
properties
um the main thing the main issue seemed
to be the
ditch which is not on the building site
but runs through the
back gardens of uh of
a number of the houses
um and it was the maintenance in those
those back gardeners that was causing
the problems
thank you council award you have your
hand up
yes thank you chairman uh yeah i went
over there with uh with councillor
michael hoy some time back
and we did have a look and we went to
the area and it would seem as if you
know
there had been
some building of how can i put a private
pub at the back of someone's garden
and um
you know just extended on their own area
and it may may have caused some of the
the blockages that were going on there's
nothing much we could do about it
but it might be noted that
we may need to have an enforcement
officer going around the back there just
to have a look because that ditch is
on
off of the
uh the main development area and is in
across the private gardens which should
be maintained by themselves i guess
again this is a riparian ownership thing
like i would imagine
and somebody has decided you know in
their building maybe blocked
those ditches up
thank you
um
right moving on to the dome caravan park
uh
yes got a comment from essex highways
and
they're saying in this area essex
highways have limited gullies the
gullies are dependent on the adjacent
ditches being cleared
um my understanding is that they are not
adequately maintained by the adjacent
land over landowners
thank you
um now i've been approached by a
resident who has confirmed exactly what
you've said um but um
there's valves and gates floodgates and
stuff left open in the open position but
silted up um
i wonder whether together with the
portfolio holder a uh site visit could
be arranged down there so that i can see
it for myself but clearly it's a
it seems to be a maintenance issue which
we as an authority need to
get on to if it is an enforcement issue
council stanley
thank you chairman yes um i'm often past
that area
and and you're quite right um there's
very lack there is somewhat of lack of
maintenance around there
um
so i'm not at all surprised um as you
say uh perhaps we can
uh somehow i don't know how we can
enforce the right parent owners of the
park
uh to do some more maintenance than what
they're doing at the moment but it would
be gratefully received i'm sure
thank you very much indeed um
uh holdbridge road opposite labard's
farm
yeah if i may chairman just before we
move on from the dome
uh i will be doing a site visit uh
coming up soon um it's actually with one
of our housing team
but we will be meeting with the
person who deals with the on-site
maintenance
um and i'll take the opportunity to talk
to them about uh sort of what's
happening
i also have contact with the
uh
the the sort of overall owners of the of
the site which are a company elsewhere
um and and i have sort of contacts there
for their maintenance and i have spoken
to them about maintenance before so
as an initial um step i i can certainly
follow that up and see what response i
get okay well certainly jeff i would
like um
to be involved in a site visit um visit
with the um particular resident and
opportunity for the portfolio holder
together with the world councillors to
uh visit the site so that we can decide
what we're gonna collectively do
essex highways comments
uh the site was visited last week
following heavy rainfall
no flooding was observed
and the essex highways ditch although
looks untidy with vegetation is
functioning adequately
and we are not aware of any asset
defects here
no works are planned at this time
thank you
thank you um
uh councillor stanley okay
sorry to have again
keep jumping in like i am but it is my
area um just to say that the the new
roundabout where the the drains have
been
uh put in at the roundabout
unfortunately they all got blocked up
with leaves
and therefore some of the some of the
water was going to walls hull bridge in
the road unfortunately not in the ditch
but the ditch that has been produced at
the side of the roundabout the new ditch
seems to be taking a considerable amount
of water nevertheless um unfortunately
with all the
the debris that comes down from hambro
hill hits that roundabout somewhat
atrociously
um we cannot stop it in any way
but we do need to keep control of the
clearing the drains around that
roundabout
and and the zebra crossing thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much and grasmere avenue and the
drive
yes
the issue here is is sort of resolving
the um
uh
ownership sorry that's the word i was
looking for uh is resolving the
ownership of the the the sort of land
between uh
sort of between the back gardens of two
roads there
um
we've done some searches and it shows
that a sort of unregistered
land so none of the agencies
have either sort of responsibilities or
powers to act
i mean i did look when i was down there
and couldn't you couldn't even identify
access to the area it does it does seem
to be sort of very enclosed by the
gardens
um
i mean it really does seem to be
something for resolution by the
the residents because again it's it's
sort of development of um
sort of in that area which seems to be
causing the problems
okay
okay
yeah it's a little unsatisfactory from
the resident's point of view
we need to sort of think how we can
work with residents on that
all right no further coming all right um
okay moving on to
rabie rorith um flooding on london road
[Music]
yes i think the
this this was what was covered by
dave chapman and uh
his sort of earlier update i believe is
that correct
yeah uh as far as i'm aware the aurora
is what we made myself uh myself from
roger on earlier so yeah this further
[Music]
what's happening now thank you
okay council aboard
yeah thank you um i i visited that area
um no it's not mine but um i i was down
there and i went into one of the shops
and they said they were flooded
uh along there um obviously
i've seen it before it's like a bone
wave that goes down that london road
when it gets flooded
um
i have no idea what can be done about it
it just seems to flood down there from
raleigh it seems to be a natural
watercourse so
i'm just interested to hear on on what's
going to happen ongoing
council stanley
thank you chairman uh again um this is
uh london road um
which uh
obviously uh the wall has been said the
water comes down off of uh
the hill um
part of the
uh ditches on the to the left-hand side
some of the ditches have been dealt with
and and uh cleared
but part of the ditches that that is the
other side of the shops on that side the
ditch there it doesn't do anything it's
full of
god knows what i wouldn't like to say
but it hasn't been cleared and hasn't
been cleared for some time in fact last
year when the ditch was cleared it was
outside the shops but didn't continue
unfortunately and i don't know who's
that down to where he says his county
council or what but it part where
in front of the shops it was cleared but
no further no fur not further on and i
suggest that that that could help
towards uh the flooding and the flooding
was in victoria avenue on the corner of
the i can't remember the first road but
on the corner in victoria avenue the
ditch that leads round the back of the
properties um
i've i from what i've heard and it's
only from what i've heard that
some residents have
built over the ditch in other words
extended their gardens and if they're
put in pipes it should be an open ditch
all the way down the back of the gardens
in fact some of it has got pipes in and
if those pipes are blocked then
the two properties on the corner of that
victoria road they do get flooded and
they had 18 inches of water this past
week when we had flooding um i noticed
that you've only got london road in
there jeff i suggest you put in church
road and the rest of rory because that
is a major major problem um of which i'd
like to speak on after this thank you
okay
thank you councillor stanley um swain
park
uh yes i mean just to uh if i may mr
chairman uh respond to councillors
stanley
and
yes i did get several reports as you say
around the
victoria road swain close sort of area
that came in
uh when we had the recent heavy rain
um it's by this time the uh the
information had gone out for this
meeting but uh i will certainly be
adding that detail to them thank you
very much
um
yes swain swain
park um
i've i've no more to add than than
what's there at the moment i don't know
if there's anybody else can help on that
one
yes sure i'll jump in on this one again
if you like um this is basically going
through the statutory console t process
much in the same way as which uh
plum row avenue did that were reported
on earlier
uh as far as i'm aware the confrontation
hasn't gone out yet but it is due to go
out soon um and uh i can send an update
to jeff once that i know a bit more
about the states with that consultation
response but that's without steam for
this responsibility
thank you thank you dave councillor
stanley you seem to be chipping in with
every point can we keep it very brief
please
please yes thank you chairman again this
is part of my area and um
swain park the car park entrance to
swain park
um
does get flooded and it comes off of the
park itself i have been in contact with
marcus and adam onbridge aldridge uh
about putting a ditch into a putting a
uh um
not a ditch a land drain into the ditch
at the front
swain park um i'm waiting for reports on
that as they've got to do a study from
what i understand uh of heights and and
with a thalodomite to
to understand where the water goes thank
you
thank you councillor stanley is the
flooding there and i'm not familiar with
the area but is the flooding air causing
a particular problem or is it just a
large puddle that takes time to go
it's causing a problem to the properties
adjacent to the entrance okay but that
certainly needs to be looked into yeah
yeah
um
jeff
uh
yes again uh
no further update that i'm aware of the
nest angling water
uh
are able to join us at the moment
yeah i can give you an update on that
can you hear me
yeah you can
okay so obviously we put new pumps in
2016 because of this was raised we've
done a trend with the telemetry we've
got for that pumping station for the
last five years
um during adverse weather the pumps
operate perfectly
what we're going to do now is jetting
and cctv of the actual
trunk sewers on grove road to make sure
there's no issues with the sewers
running into the station
that's during the next four weeks to be
completed so as soon as i get an update
on that i can let everybody know
thank you very much eastwood road
uh chairman can i come in please sorry
councillor missed you sorry yeah thank
you um yeah because because driver uh in
my area uh they had serious flooding
there the other week
um sewage
lots of complaints i sent photos
to jeff
which i assume he would have passed on
to you so you can have a look at
um
we know there is a serious capacity
issue there and has been for quite a
time
we were promised a serious update in the
pumping we're not talking about 2016 we
were looking at monies being invested in
2020 obviously we covered they weren't
2021 was the date obviously we're
running out of 2021
2022 and i know mark francois the mp was
very much involved initially in this and
had a conversation with your chief
executive mr simpson i believe
um in regards to this and i believe he
would like a report back as to what is
being done because as far as he can see
nothing is being done because all he's
getting is complaints so i don't know if
you can try and get something on that
please mark uh to come back to jeff in
some way or another because i know that
he's getting lots of letters
and uh nothing seems to be occurring i'm
sure it is but they just want to know
the promises that simpson made that this
would be sorted out
i mean it's with the flood modeling team
at anglian water um they're heavily
reliant on the surveys that we're going
to do
we need to do full cctv surveys so that
we can
see the integrity of our pipework make
sure everything's fine once we give that
data to them um i'll then chase the
flood team that we've got
and ask them to put together some sort
of report so that we can at least give a
proper update
yeah thank you mark and if i can just i
noticed it's not on rayleigh which is
another ring ditch um i just need to ask
jeff uh the maintenance of that ditch
when uh is the date uh set for that
maintenance to carry out and also i did
send you a report that on the last bit
of flooding we've had parts of the
embankment fall away and quite concerned
residents are concerned because that is
an integral part of protecting the whole
of the poet's estate
uh and that could be flooded if that
disappears so i just wondered if if
roger from the environment agency would
carry out an inspection just to check on
you know
the safety and if any remedial work
needs to be done on that debt on the
ditch whether he will be looking to
carry that out because obviously for one
meter up i believe it still is
environment agency
responsibility um and although we clear
the vegetation to get the flow now
now
uh could you send me the details council
what it won't be me specifically doing
it
on to our asset performance team to have
a look
i sent it all to uh to jeff to actually
uh undertake that last week to check
that out on both of those issues so i
would appreciate you know that but also
if jeff do you know when the maintenance
i think adam aldridge is possibly in
charge of that part i don't know if dave
could help ghostberry
i'm not sure about that you know i'll
have to have a word with adam
okay the important thing is the issue is
locked for the purposes of this meeting
uh capital award thank you very much
indeed
can i just put in one other thing um i
sent in another one uh basically unknown
was from green uh someone that
stuck in a
dishwasher or dumped some kind of washer
in in the in the actual ditch which
needs to be removed that's all that was
only recent over the weekend this is in
eastwood road is it
uh this is no this is in nobles green
ditch
that's that's not initially that's an
environment issue ian
if you could have had an email to that
effect
okay i haven't had it okay
okay and i don't know how i missed your
bright yellow hand on that occasion
council
apologies so
right moving on to hotly road
um
yeah just covering eastwood road
um
yes not sure where we go with that one
the essex highways comment
is that their stance is unchanged uh
it's not classed as an adopted
maintained
maintainable public highway
um
so we're
not quite sure how we we establish who
the responsibility is for for that one
in eastwood road
eastwood road and eastwood rise
again
can i come back on this this is ongoing
um
this uh apparently when the works were
done
along eastwood rise
the road should have been adopted uh
this was promised to the residents in a
letter by a gentleman called philip lord
who was essence county council
uh i passed that letter on to
um sean stratton who was the managed
director and he sent it on to the legal
department at essex
that letter is still in
essex and they are still determining
how they're going to deal
with this this seems to be a legal issue
that i think they have disavowed philip
lord
um from them
although he was acting on their behalf
okay jeff you made a note of that
yeah
if it helps i can take that offline with
jeff to fill him in okay all right i'm
just concerned we need to speed it up a
bit and get through these items but uh
it's all useful background information
right
i think we're at hockley road now aren't
we
yeah um
that was a report that uh
i
i got um
i went had a look following uh heavy
rain
i think further work have been done on
the site and and certainly i i didn't uh
see any evidence and essex highways have
commented they're not aware of any
highway maintenance issues there
um
so um
yes they feel it's something if there is
a problem that should be addressed
through the uh through the developer
okay councillor sparing i know you've
been oh yeah you've got your hand up
actually
yeah i i think the settling tank is in
the wrong place uh chairman it's it's at
the top of the development and the water
is all running down down from it i mean
it hardly gets filled up but i was out
there when we were having some very
heavy rain there was hardly any water in
the settlement tank but further down the
road going through everybody's houses
and gardens it was quite torrential so
my my feeling is that the the settling
tank has been put in the wrong place but
uh
perhaps we can discuss that i've i've
highlighted it previously but uh
you know i don't quite know where we go
from this
but it should be a fairly
straightforward planning matter i would
have thought yeah
yeah
right so that's within the remit of rdc
to talk about that yes i think it is
okay all right i'm sure the appropriate
action has been recorded there i'd like
to know the outcome of that
moving on to rockford sutton road
uh highways comment there
um
they're just saying there's nothing
further to add at this time
sorry counselor
yeah with regards to southern roads uh i
have had received notification
notifications counsellor that some
drainage works are going to be carried
out at the junction of birdies and
something road
which means closing the road overnight
for six days
um
i'm unable to determine what that
drainage work is
whether it is connected to this
particular issue or whether it's a
different issue
to date i've not received a back of any
emails from anybody
to inform exactly what the situation is
there so i don't know
i don't know um
david are you able to help there
no again unfortunately my colleagues in
essex highways haven't reported anything
to me
but
i'll try and follow that with if need be
or i can
have a conversation with richard to see
whether he knows any more about it
okay um well certainly
so just quickly come back on that uh
could you correspond with me by with
that by direct email please
yes no problem
yeah i mean certainly yeah i was just
going to say that as part of your
division counselor you're um you would
always expect dialogue direct with
officers
moving on to full road development
development
yes both this and the uh the next one
the rockford hundreds uh golf club
um when
we have the meeting with environment
agency
those are both areas that we that we
want to have a
look at and how they link into the uh
the main water courses
thank you councillor scepter again yes
thank you
thank you um with regards to the whole
road
uh i am actually meeting with planning
offices tomorrow on site
because it appears that the drainage
that runs along full road itself
from the new roundabout towards rock
uh is not being connected into the sub
system
and it's still running into the original
ditch that runs back up along the back
of the properties in oak road
so we suspect that it may be they've
complied with training conditions at
this stage but that is something that
i'm meeting with officers tomorrow to
discuss
thank you councillor council award
from what i understand i think noble's
green ditch and i think uh
once there's the other one that comes
through wyburns wood they join up and
they actually end up going through um
rochford 100 golf club
so you know when there's heavy rain
literally just it just floods vast areas
of the course
thank you very much um
right moving on to the weekend if i
could come back on that just to so
just to clarify the water and the sun
systems from hall road
run over under i will run into the
drainage system there then run along the
front of west street
and join in by the reservoir they don't
actually feed in by the
golf course
thank you um
right moving on to the wakerings
the high street in great wakering
yeah update from essex highways
uh the surface water alleviation scheme
uh was brought forward
uh and works were undertaken to the
drainage system in august 2021
sections of the pipe were replaced and
repaired
and the system was tested and left
working
it has been monitored during rainfall
although there have been reports that
the water is still holding during heavy
rainfall
this may of course be a capacity issue
due to the extreme rainfall but uh they
will contin but will continue to be
monitored
thank you councillor joe mcpherson
um thank you chairman um just just i
think you might want to put on their
days between 2 four nine two five three
the high street jeff just so you noted
on that um yeah council lee scott did
um email and say exactly what you've
just said jeff about the ad hoc jetta
seem to have alleviated it
however it is still flooding
and it's just not good enough that my
residents are told that it's purely down
to capacity issue we need to do
something about this
i wonder if our lovely anglian water
gentleman mark might be able to consider
doing the sort of um
was it like jet washing that you did
down little wakering road
yeah we're happy to do that we're
sitting on a bit of a backpack at the
minute as you can imagine after the
storm we've just had but i'm happy to
send the cctv unit down there one of our
recycled lorries
um they'll give it a clean throw and
they'll put a rugby camera down to check
everything
i can get that arranged
bashing our liaison you can get that the
details and the person sent to you thank
you
yeah
so thanks for that mark and uh thank you
joe um
councillor steple again yeah thank you
uh
uh for that uh there's uh two areas in
great waking that i'm dealing with with
regards to what you're talking about
there's one outside the properties that
joe has mentioned there's also
the same similar situation out number
side number 75
uh where pipes have been replaced
uh i've got a horrible feeling that the
pipes that council scott is referring to
were the ones adjacent to 75 and not the
other way i need to clarify that
but having said that it's the water flow
running into the
water system
uh they have been jetted through
not too long ago
but it is a capacity issue
what i've asked county to look at and
are waiting for engineers to come back
to me
is to look at the profiling of the road
so the water spreads along the road
more evenly rather than to pond outside
particular properties so that's
something that i'm working currently at
the moment to see whether that's
possible to to actually achieve we were
successful with that with outside some
other properties people close to the
church
which seems to alleviate problems so it
just spreads the water out
through the system rather than all in
one place
okay um thank you could that item be
adjusted so as it reflects more
precisely the specific addresses that
appears to
relate to two distinct areas within the
um within the high street uh please just
as we
get some tie up on those um darling road
uh yes comment from um
highways
to say the ditch on the western side is
on the main
river map
so not an essex highways asset to to
maintain
so if that's
main river that
that would suggest environment agency
i'm not i'm not over familiar with that
area so i'm not sure
and we have uh councilman
hand up and then elsewhere
thank you again chairman um
i think um um i might pass this back
over to um councillor scepter because i
think he may mention what i'm going to
raise is the fact that some a resident
has sent a pitch through of a pipe that
is distilling water onto the highway by
the shoulder stick
though that could cause this issue as
well
yes thank you yes we are working on that
the the ditch that you're referring to
jeff is what's known as mackin brooke
it is the main watercourse at lunchtime
from south end
to the roach
uh it is
under the
ownership of uh
in parts by this table
uh it is monitored by the environmental
agency but not maintained
uh it has come up several times in this
particular
context
at the point that
with regards to the
thank you very much
thank you very much kimberly road
here with the the environment agency to
look at
a lot of the issues in the in the area
there
um
the there was a report uh about erosion
to a back fence from a watercourse
um
but in fact the
the whole area had been created by them
creating a drive
um
rather than any anything that had been
done in relation to the water course
um
so
really we're saying that is is a sort of
responsibility of the of the owner
um essex county council highways have
done maintenance on the road gullies in
in that area
there's also a pumping station there the
pumps of which have been replaced
um but at the time we did the report
there hadn't been any heavy rain so
there um angling water may be able to
update us on that um
and then the the sluice gate
was a sort of issue there
um
but we sort of had a look at that and
and
couldn't really see any any sort of
particular issues
um so really i think the only action
that's still outstanding on that one is
to get back to the uh
uh the owners who suffered the erosion
to say it's
you know it's it's where the drive to uh
an additional property is has been built
and the uh the maintenance of that is
their responsibility
can i jump in there as well jeff because
there was a
gay you remember richard we met with
richard and bennett's a few years ago
so we replaced the duck bill flat there
but the landwood side of that rochford
rochford uh are responsible for that
richard at the time was going to replace
the gate
upstream but that would never happened
so
i'm not sure whether that's added in
your report i'm just reading your report
i'm just reading your football
oh yeah yeah
the bottom there yeah yeah so i don't
know whether rochford are going to
replace that
um and
right
we've got um councillor joe mcpherson
and then councilman mike stefan
thank you
thank you chairman um i did email over
jeff because the works that were meant
to be done by the
house were subsiding into the ditch have
been done
by three four four a liter waking road
and also the bungalow to the rear number
67 kimberly they've both completed the
works glenn shaw kindly came out from
essex county council wrote to them
that's been done
there's still some overgrowth that
concerns local residents but there
hasn't been any flooding issues since
and i think a huge help to that has been
mark again and his team who sort of
power flashed down the um
drainage system
but there's concerns that it will come
back again so i just wanted to know if
mark can say whether that could be done
annually
yeah that's that should be on a six
monthly
maintenance program now so the work that
we carried out when we were all on site
that would be
that should be happening every six
months
wonderful thank you it may not be a
camera server every six months but the
line will be cleaned through by the
lorry every six months
thank you you're doing well this
afternoon councilman you're getting a
commitment from anglia walter on
everything you're requesting so well
well done uh councillor
yes thank you um this is the one item
that i do need to clear declare a
personal interest in
uh because of this stream
upstream runs through my garden
so it is something that i monitor
extremely closely for obvious reasons
the as joe says the repairs have been
done to the
side wall which had collapsed
[Music]
there is a concern that there may be a
blockage there um
i'm not sure who is responsible for that
particular section
uh because it disappears underground uh
just to jump into my garden and it
doesn't come up under until it gets to
the
bit by legendary road i think it's um
angry water but i need to be certain
that perhaps we can have some
clarification on that that may need to
be re-camera again to see whether that
is now clear
thank you very much
thank you uh council watson can i i
didn't really get an answer about this
grill upstream are rochford going to be
replacing that
can i just come in can i just come in on
that
um the original works going back some 15
years ago when the last the division dug
out
uh was under the control of rock at that
time
but my understanding what i've been
given is when the
um
lead flood forum was created
and it was therefore handed over to
essex county
so i think it may now be the
responsibility of missiles
rather than a rockford district
i i only ask this question whoever it is
because what happens sometimes in the
holidays
the they what kids open the grou the
grill or the the bill flap which allows
water to come back up and puts
risk on the properties when there is a
high tide
so a grill down there needs to be
actioned else we're going to have the
same problem in the future
okay well your point has been noted and
jeff if you can recall that
in conjunction with the portfolio holder
uh we'll look into that so uh
i can't demonstrate scientific interrupt
can roger contact me with that offline
please
please what do you want me to sorry i
don't know what i'm more i can say i've
met with jeff
we've outlined the issues there
um
richard tattenberg at the time said they
were going to sort out this grill
and it's still not been sorted out
we've done our bit we've replaced the
the dope bill flap from the original
flat that was one of the old flaps which
kids left open with the duckbill flap
that is not so easily possible now
we've done our bit we're expecting
somebody to do the other bit else we're
gonna have the same problem that's the
only point i'm making
and i do have further information on
that but it's not here worth going
through it here now if you contact me
offline i'll explain the situation
okay and if that action be called can be
coordinated through jeff stacy so that
it becomes a meaningful update on that
item
thank you very much
thank you very much
um right i think we're down to pointers
lane in wakering road now
yes uh comment from essex highways
bellies here were attended and
2020 uh 2021
uh it was noted that the ditches needed
further maintenance
um which is a riparian owner
responsibility
okay um
thank you
can i come in on this one please yeah
sure
right
i'm not sure exactly what you're talking
about here on this particular section
uh there is some road work to do to be
carried out with the junction of um
waking road and um
that should should be starting over the
next couple of months or so but some of
those ditches that run along the side of
the mountains there
over right orlando who's actually the
amount mod
thank you councilman christine mason
thank you mr christine mason
mr chairman i'd like to with your
permission go back on a previous item
when you've completed pointlessly
okay i think we've completed pointers
lane in terms of uh
noting the comments um so
that you go back by always
thank you apologies for this but i had
the uh details very late and haven't
managed to read it all before today
um
i'm going back to hawkwood brooke i've
only just seen the report by the officer
and i can probably add some clarity to
that
to assist on the area of woodland
woodside road
and elmwood where the the cardboard goes
under the road
and there's a ditch by it woodside chase
um i noticed that the report says the it
indicates that this stretches russia
district council
um going back and i'm going back now um
i hope this helps mr stacy over 10 years
roger i think it was roger cornwell who
you you probably
will recall
was then in charge of
these
issues
we had a site visit
there was flooding on that issue and the
floods actually went down to hawthorne
chase and blockages were flooded
including the one on the corner of
elmwood out avenue
it was essentially at that time that the
responsibility for that um
culvert and the the
part of the road was in fact angry water
and at the at the point that point in
time and walter had a gate i'm not sure
if it's still there unlockable gate must
admit i haven't looked recently
they had a lockable gate there and they
gave the key
to
the gentleman that lived in number one i
think it was number one woodside but the
property next to it beside chase because
the residents used to jump over and
clear clear it out
because of the um
infrequency perhaps that the authorities
doing so it's all not the same
so that hopefully that added information
helps if you want any more information
online mr spacey i'm quite happy to give
it to you thank you
really helpful thank you councilman
mason um
now
we've been through the summary uh this
this log
and that really becomes the core
document uh for this meeting um because
issues on there need some formal
attention or resolution so i'm very very
grateful to jeff stacy for pulling
together um but it becomes a living
document and i think there's some work
that needs to be done over the next week
or two and to just bring it up to speed
in the life of this meeting but this
will become the uh regular document for
the flood forum um because those are the
things that give us real focus
uh in terms of what we're addressing so
uh thanks to uh all our partners thanks
to jeff
for uh putting that together and um
thanks to ward councillors for feeding
in valuable information council aboard
thank you chairman um i just want to go
uh to add something if i may it goes
back um to home bridge and kingsman farm
road now it didn't come up on anything
at all but
i have an item here which i don't know
if jeff is aware of and i don't know
whether we have anything to do with to
be honest but um
one of the uh members of hulbridge
parish council sent
this to me asking about the progress on
insurance repair to the sea wall defense
at kingsman farm road now i wonder if
that has any impact on on kingsman farm
and
could anyone help me with this so i can
come back because
i really don't know i haven't got an
answer to it
okay um well perhaps the answer will
come offline from jeff stacy who can
coordinate this
and i really do want to move forward
otherwise
the whole idea of going through the
report was to take it line by line which
is what we've done i don't really want
to revisit loads of items on there um um
council awards can you take that offline
and work with um
update the item please
i will
send the email i'll forward the email to
him that i've received and maybe he can
deal with it directly then please
thank you very much council uh mr
christine mason
thank you mr chairman um
you want to appreciate this is the first
time that i've been allowed to be
involved in this report and i found it
quite illuminating
and it's very constructive but i like
the way it's done but i would like to
see some further information
on the report if the committee so agrees
i was very concerned with councillor
shots of the pakistan
thing had been
um
an issue since 2008 and i must admit
i've been aware of it for about 10 years
so
we're concerned that it was even longer
than that i wonder if we could have the
dates when these items are first
reported on there which would rather
flag up
whether or not we're being proactive
enough on that particular situation
would that be possible just to have the
instigation date against the
location please i think that's a really
good idea
and it's all part of building up a
detailed report which i suggest
because this will become the detailed
report and there will be a probably a
summary spreadsheet or something
just to give us a feel and i think we
need
some sort of red amber green um approach
i think this this is a good start
because it becomes the core
document that it has a focus of
attention on but i think we need to
build it up um certainly with the date
for inception
because the one thing that i don't like
is things just roll round around around
we need to actually get some conclusive
action to resolve issues rather than
talking about the memory club forum um
so i would certainly support that point
uh
thank you mr president thank you
um councillor stanley i do want to move
on but uh
yes thank you chairman um could i ask uh
should for this uh
committee if you like
could we have a detailed perhaps a
drawing or something to indicate where
this flooding has occurred and what what
uh what we're doing um we don't seem to
have i know we're talking about areas
and those
uh councillors that are that do
represent those areas they know where
the flooding is but those of us that
don't uh we'd like i'd like to see if
we've got a map or something like that
that can go with the comments
um is that well i think in fairness
council stanley the whole idea of this
certainly the reason why the portfolio
holder and i agreed to broadening it is
exactly what happened this afternoon or
councillors who represent a particular
area to chip in so that they get
feedback you know i mean we've got to be
a little bit careful we don't create a
whole bureaucracy around it we want to
keep it pretty pretty slick and relevant
to our small areas so that
council is on top of issues
okay thank you thank you the other thing
i wanted to uh emphasize on this
particular agenda was the flooding uh in
rorith uh basically uh i know it's been
said that i'm having talks with uh
godzilla stanley councilman stanley the
whole idea of going around the area was
to focus on the particular areas and
then of course that become this becomes
a living document
and then we feed it in through other
issues either being raised by members or
members of the public
and i do really want to structure an
approach otherwise we end up by going
all over the place you know just picking
out the one that's a hot spot to that
particular counselor so
my whole objective with the flood forum
is to get some real structure and
accountability around the issues and
who's dealing with it and i think we've
made really good progress this afternoon
through principally our partners and uh
jeff stacey's approach to this report
i'll take your point but i don't want to
just go all over the place
yeah well one one other thing is was can
we get something from essex highways to
to come in and comment as uh davey
chapman has to be the
the go-between if you like uh is it
possible to get somebody from essex
highways well i i agree with you um i
think it's it's good progress i spoke to
the portfolio holder last week to say
that i was expecting there to be someone
from the highways and um i'm most
grateful that dave chapman has joined in
but
i do think a um highways representative
will assist and support him but uh how
it's done um i'm pretty relaxed but they
are a key partner in this process and
you're absolutely right now i'd like to
move on to the next
point if i made
i'm conscious of time
and i want to conclude it by four
o'clock and we have questions from the
public and uh welcome to members of the
public who are viewing us this afternoon
and we'll look at the recording of this
meeting
but it's important that we go through
those questions so that we can feed uh
public questions into the document if we
think appropriate jeff do you want to
talk to us through the public questions
have they been circulated to members of
the forum
uh yes i believe they were
correct me if i'm wrong in that
assumption right well i think we're
getting some mixed responses some yeses
and some knows um so public questions
are very important
i'd be grateful if you could make sure
in future that all
members of the forum are included
and as good practice everyone needs all
documentation completed
several days in advance of the meeting
bearing in my time constraints if you
can run us through the questions please
yes yeah no it was my understanding that
said that they had been circulated
um
yeah the first um well in fact i've
linked two questions together they're
the sort of neighbors in uh in cornhill
avenue hockerly
and the recent heavy rainfall
has shown up some some sort of issues
there
um so that's certainly something to uh
to be added to the list for for some
further investigation
uh i mean i'll certainly have a look
into it and then report back to uh to
partners to
to see if we can see quite what the
issues are and what further improvements
can be made there
okay well the good news is that we've
agreed that it's an item that's going to
be added to the list so
that will go on there so for
investigation
some members don't know what we're
talking about
yeah and
the next question was
around flooding in folly lane
um
which is on a blind bend and vehicles
have difficulty getting passed through
the the the flood water
um
yes i mean that one where we'll refer to
highways
but yeah i think it may also be linked
to another
uh inquiry that i've had very recently
so it's not reflected in any of the of
the paperwork
um for somebody
just sort of down the hill from that
who was
was having
issues with their garden flooding from a
drain
um
so
something
yeah again something to be added for
further investigation to
try and look at
what the
issue is there
but certainly in in the first instance
the
flooding on folly lane will be referred
to essex highways
thank you um
question three
why are we not paying the local farmers
landowners to clear or dredge
predictions and causeways
yes just really asking for any comment
by partners if if they do engage them
that way
no one's chipping it but i think the
key thing here is to hold people who
have ditches or drainage systems running
through their land to be accountable for
um making sure that they're maintained
and for
us or the relevant authority to have
enforcement processes in place to ensure
that they are complying because water is
no respecter of boundaries and the lack
of maintenance in one area could well
force
water to drain on or flood someone
else's land so i think it's all about uh
consideration and
consideration having this list will
focus on what we need to do as an
authority or engage with other
authorities to make sure enforcement
takes place that's
most of the ditches that the farmers are
responsible for are obviously come under
right parent ownership including those
that run along the edge of the road
so it should be the responsibility of
the farmers
and i do know that uh county uh as they
had come to berlin creek we talked about
earlier on have actually written out to
the landowners
and reminded them of their
responsibility and i've had several
cases where that has been the case
thank you council receptor council
sparring
no council steptoe spawn german
exactly the case and uh perhaps we could
bring our uh our own legal people into
play and uh help county and uh anybody
else on this issue but it it is as
counselor steptoe said spot on
yep totally certainly agree
um and within the framework of the law
um provide chargeback if we uh incur
costs any of the authorities to get
landowners to do what they should be
doing as a matter of good housekeeping
on their on their land um right moving
on to question four jeff
question
yes um this is
asking who is responsible for the open
storm drain
behind a resident in swain clothes close
[Music]
and he's given
name a number
provided so i i can sort of follow
follow that up and try and establish who
is responsible for that
um
i mean it also seems to
link in if if i can sort of uh
step forward a little bit to mr chairman
and sort of question five is also around
road surface flooding in in swaying
close
off victoria avenue and question six
um is somebody writing on behalf of
their their their parents who live in
victoria avenue in raleigh
um all reporting flooding in the uh the
sort of recent
um
heavy rainfall that we've had
which
all points to uh to the fact that we
this is obviously an area that we need
to uh look into to to see what the
issues are there
okay thank you
uh thank you
thanks for sparing you've got your hand
up
historically chairman uh i believe they
did resurface a lot of the road here at
one time
um not that many years ago amazed to
tarmac over or dropped tarmac down most
of the drains so whether this is an
ongoing scenario from that time i don't
know but that was an issue a couple of
years ago
a couple of years ago thank you
thank you question seven
questions
uh
yeah they um
uh this
uh
we've spoken about this already
the um
this was uh asking for further door uh
information for angling water around uh
grove road so we've we've had a comment
from england water on that already
um
it also
went uh talked about the annual
maintenance of noble screen
ditch
um
which
uh
we have sort of covered as well and
obviously we get some comment from that
on the uh
the the environment agency
thank you
thank you
and question 8
question 8
um
this wasn't provided with any contact or
any further details
um but they'd obviously have evidenced
a cleanup team from essex and suffolk
water
jet wash all the mud and and everything
from some works undertaken down the
drain gully
rather than shoveling it up and moving
it from sides
so obviously we can pass that comment on
to to highways who
who may want to to follow it up but as i
say we've no specific details to
to be able to follow it up fully
unfortunately
okay
look i appreciate that these questions
come in a matter of days before this
meeting so it's not always possible to
have a full comprehensive answer but
certainly where possible i would like
urgent attention given to those
questions replies more comprehensive
replies given to
those that have raised them and
i would like to see along with the
portfolio holder
copies of the replies and if necessary
then put onto
the
worksheet the uh summary so that we know
what what's happening and they are
properly tracked and resolved um where
possible councillor this is christine
mason
thank you mr chairman um i've had a
request over the weekend from a resident
that would like an issue put on to the
agenda if we can world report that for
the next meeting
there's flooding apparently in the world
spencer's in hawk world i've not seen it
so i don't know what degree of severity
it is but apparently it's caused by
blocked drains i wonder if we could add
that to the list and
investigate it accordingly
okay and
if
jeff stacy needs more information
perhaps you can
contact
council mrs mason direct just to get
some specifics please
and councillor mike stepped up thank you
thank you we're picking up on your point
there about the uh
questions
um i'm sure a lot of members of the
public will be interested in the artist
should that not be in one of our
websites or should we not have an area
in their website which will answer those
questions
uh
yes that's a very good point um but
actually the questions i suggest will be
summarized and reported in the minutes
from this meeting and i think
it is those minutes that become the um
uh the formal responses to this meeting
um so i think
to keep it all in one place i think on
the minutes to summarize the questions
and that the responses is
counselor chris stanley
thank you
i'd just like to offer
uh services by time or whatever when
jeff wants to uh investigate the areas
that we've mentioned like victoria and
uh roariff and and
in such places spain park
i'm more i'm readily available so
anytime and i think that applies to all
councillors should be kept kept up to
speed with all areas in their um
in their ward areas so uh thank you
council stanley for that
right that moves us on to any other
business um
anyone got anything to raise councillor
gentlemen
thank you chairman i'll keep it brief um
it's just these guys are good enough to
come along and contribute to our flood
forum
is there any way we can support them one
example might be um
mark from anglin walter
mentioned once about
water boats and how they can prevent
surface water perhaps we could do a
campaign around that sort of thing on
social media because that's what our
residents follow at the moment
just a thought lovely thank you it's
very helpful and i'm sure veronica has
made a note of that in the in the
minutes councillor
thank you thank you chairman following
the heavy rain the other day we've got
another couple of flooding issues which
i will pull to jeff directly um there's
nothing he can do now but just be
ongoing it's blocked drains are going
i'm afraid
i'm afraid
okay
um
any other any other other other business
okay all right um well can i conclude by
uh thanking members of the public for uh
joining in this afternoon and viewing
this meeting and
i thank members
for your attendance this afternoon
i'd particularly like to thank uh dave
chapman as your county council for
joining us um it was particularly
helpful
to have you here along with roger
webster of the environment agency and of
course mark lloyd anglia walter who's
agreed to everything that uh councillor
joe mcpherson asked him so
that she's he's become a friend for life
so
there we are um but uh thank you very
much indeed um uh everyone now i'd said
at the start about um
my
enthusiasm to make these meetings
virtual in future to save people
traveling around the place
um i have to say that um i think we've
got to sort out technology certainly for
officers and jeff i think
you may have to review your um whether
or not you're going to the
uh council offices because there's been
quite a lot of feedback and i think it's
coming from the fact that you've got a
couple of screens in fact you just
confirmed it's from you know because i
think you've got a couple of screens
open and you get feedback within the
systems
um so with yeah as soon as you go on to
mute it cuts out that rather awful echo
that we'll get you know um a bit of a
time delay so i think we've got to sort
out some um
some issues with technology um
people know where they've got weak uh
internet systems and i think we've got
to try and address that this seems an
ideal meeting to to
hold virtually but what are other
members views councillor stefan
yes thank you chairman um it can be a
difficult for officers to attend
um particularly
as we know they're very busy coming from
other agencies particularly if they've
got to travel a long distance
so i would perhaps suggest that we need
to consider
some form of hybrid
meeting where officers that can't get to
us
you know easily in their busy days can
actually
attend through electronic means where
other members can be that and be actual
so i would suggest it needs to be a
combination of both
yeah unfortunately within rockford
district council we've not got very good
hybrid systems but i would certainly
support hybrid i was on a hybrid meeting
the other day working very well but not
on watch for district council premises
um
because you know our chamber just isn't
up to the speed it's not being used at
the present time for kobe's purposes but
uh hybrid is probably a way forward
equipment allowing
council award
yeah i would agree with that until such
times does we have a suitable facility i
would say that we should remain as we're
doing now just ensuring that everybody
uh can get in touch and is able to have
uh good internet connections
thank you council of this year's
chrisley mason
are you on mute
oh god why does that keep my reaction
thank you
i obviously clicked on the wrong bit
um
yes
having um observed this meeting for the
first time
um
i found it very interesting and
informative
i i would prefer the zoom meetings i
think there's a greater ability for
everyone members and officers to attend
i appreciate the
difficulty that the officer had with his
internet but i mean
presumably that can be resolved by going
into the office but there's two
advantages to this one is the time
efficiency for all of us
and that the other is
i think and i'm not an expert on this
but i'm sure councillor mcpherson will
correct me if i'm wrong it's more carbon
friendly if we don't all travel all over
the place
so
but i certainly would prefer it to be on
soon thank you
yeah i'd actually go with that provided
we've got all the connectivity and
we're just aware of the limitations of
the systems that are supporting us i
think
jeff stacy probably has the hardest job
because he needs to toggle between
different systems and be on a zoom
meeting at the same time but uh
that is overcomeable i would suggest
with modern technology council
yeah i'm just going to say that
members themselves can can't always uh
be there in person
currently i'm actually sitting in county
hall
i've had very large planning meetings
all this morning it would have been
impossible for me to get there um for
this particular meeting yeah okay
good all right well i think we've had a
little bit of a um good discussion about
that um can i thank everyone for their
attendance today uh a good session a bit
of work on you jeff to coordinate for
the uh uh next meeting but if in the
meantime next week or two you could
update the um core document because that
really is the um
the lifeblood of this particular meeting
so thank you very much thank you
veronica for taking the notes and